-We are so excited to welcom
our first guest tonight
who is an Oscar-nominated
and Emmy Award-winning actor
and comedy legend whose hi
films include "Trading Places,
"Beverly Hills Cop," "The Nutt
Professor," and "Shrek."
He reprises his role
as Prince Akeem Joffer
in the highly anticipated film
"Coming 2 America,"
which is streaming
on Amazon Prime Video now.
Please welcome to the show
the one, the only Eddie Murphy
How are you, Eddie?
-Hey. How are you, Seth?
-Absolutely thrilled
to have you here.
-Aw, thank you so much.
-I know it seems like
a million years ago,
mostly because there was
a full audience in the studio --
and thank God for that --
but you did go back
and you hosted "SNL"
after an incredibly long break
And I just wonder,
how quickly did it come back
Did muscle memory kick in fo
what a week at "SNL" was like?
-Yeah, it does.
You know from doing that show.
It's such a grind.
Once you leave there,
I found that, 36 years later
you can go back and
you fall right back into it.
It was surreal.
It was like going back
to the old high school.
-You know, this film, one of the
most wonderful things about it
is seeing people
who were in the first movie,
but it was especially exciting
for me to see the new characters
you welcomed into the film
I'm very good friends
with Leslie Jones.
-Leslie Jones.
Leslie Jones in this movie
-Right?
-Leslie Jones. Oh. So funny.
-I mean, I said to her, "Look.
It's always great to kill
in a movie, which you did,
but you killed in a movie
alongside Eddie Murphy."
And that just must be
such a thrill for her.
How long have you been aware
of Leslie?
-For years.
I saw Leslie years ago in, like,
an after-hours comedy club
like, downtown L.A.
with some spot that was maybe,
like, 15 people were in.
It was like 4:00 in the morning,
and that's when I first saw her.
And it was -- She turned it out.
She's always like, "I wish
you don't remember that show."
She killed. It was, like,
this after-hours place.
And I saw her
at the Laugh Factory,
so I was aware of her
as a comic.
-I mean, in a way,
you're sort of putting togethe
a superhero team
when you cast these movies
because it strikes me
that you have this, like,
sort of multigenerational cast
and it must be tastes of yours
from when you're a kid.
You know, for example,
when you have James Earl Jones
And then, obviously, younger
actors who you've obviously seen
and thought, "They're
going to be great in this.
-Absolutely. Absolutely.
I did a movie years ago,
"Harlem Nights,"
with Richard Pryor and Red Foxx.
That was another one
of those movies
where it was older generatio
and the new comics.
Robin Harris --
a great comic that passed away
He was in the movie, as well
And my brother Charlie.
And, yeah,
I kind of get a kick out of,
you know, connecting
with the older ones,
with the younger ones,
and being in the middle.
-I recently saw --
It was posted online by Netflix.
It was Arsenio Hall
telling a story
about Richard Pryor once
bringing you up on stage.
I believe at The Comedy Store.
Was he always nice?
-He was always super-nice to me,
Richard.
Always super-nice.
-But he brought you on stage
according to this story,
and then he just sat on the edge
of stage while you did your set.
Was that intimidating
or was it thrilling?
-That was thrilling.
I turned it out.
It was like --
He was sitting there.
I wanted to show off.
Like, "Watch this!" You know
Just to make him laugh
was amazing.
So, no,
I wasn't intimidated at all.
-One of your daughters plays one
of the princesses in the film.
-Yes, my beautiful baby girl
Bella.
-Uh, of your kids,
is she the only one who's show
sort of a taste
for being on camera so far
-Well, no, all of my kids --
or most of my kids are actin
or writing or, you know,
have interest in the arts.
-That is --
Nor can you blame them.
It's certainly turned out
very well for you.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Um, I have more questions
We'll be right back
with Eddie Murphy after this